if you are living in New York City right
now cost of living differential between
New York and Miami is two to one so in
New York the median home price is a
million dollars in Miami median home
price is 540 two to one right in
addition to that in New York you're
paying 50 if you're in the highest tax
bracket a lot of New Yorkers are because
again your cost of living well they're
all coming down here now well but check
it out let's do the math right you're
paying 54 cents out of every dollar in
taxes that means that for every dollar
you earn you take home 46 cents in Miami
you get 63 cents right it is a huge
Delta right and so that when you at
scale obviously is incredibly uh
motivating to people you know I've seen
statistics that seventy percent of the
taxes in New York are paid by 8 000
people and if that becomes seventy five
hundred and seven thousand sixty five
hundred you get what's called a vicious
cycle right you get massive holes in
your budget when those people leave and
there's only one way to get more revenue
for them which is to increase taxes
which creates more migration more holes
and I call it the death spiral foreign
Rubin we are at the local Studio here in
Miami and I am with the mayor of Miami
Francis Suarez who loves Miami fair to
say you love Miami nobody loves my
everyone loves Miami but like you love
me there's no separation between me and
Miami right like first of all just
coming here and seeing this incredible
studio in the heart of Wynwood in Miami
which is one of the most dynamic fun
exciting neighborhoods it's totally on
brand for you right and uh you know it's
just exciting to see you here and uh we
so we totally Embrace what you're doing
you know in terms of the content the
conversations that you're provoking and
it's very much in line with who we are
as a city so it's just it's just fun and
exciting to be here so I asked my guys
right before we started I sat down with
you in Miami Beach in June of 2021
that's right so it's about it a little
less than a year and a half ago I was
not a Floridian I was not really
thinking about Florida there was a
little there was a little bit
okay there was a little something but a
lot has changed for for me and this
company and and you're basically in
charge of the city that everyone is
coming to right now how do you feel
about that because I know it's good but
it also comes with some some stuff
that's tough right so look first of all
as the first mayor of Miami that was
born in Miami right in the 125 year
history of Miami this is a dream come
true I feel like every day I'm living a
dream insofar as I was born here I grew
up here went to college here uh lost
your dad was mayor my dad was a mayor
from when I was eight years old to when
I was 16 so I saw this sort of evolution
of the city very up close uh and and to
be in a situation where we have set up a
city to be successful when a lot of
urban cities in America are not
successful or failing and we did it
because we followed three Simple Rules
we keep taxes low we keep people safe
and we lean into Innovation so you know
we have created a city that's number one
in Tech job growth right number one in
wage growth we have a city that because
we've kept taxes low has grown 12
percent which is the second most in
recorded history and with all that
additional Revenue even though you lower
taxes you actually have more Revenue
right you know sport learner for New
York and California right uh we have
actually done the opposite of what other
cities have done which have defunded
their police with increased funding for
police more officers than ever another
shocking correlation
our crime is about to be God willing you
know I knock on Woodward right there
we're not in December yet uh but we are
on the precipice of having the lowest
per capita homicide rate in history yeah
so it's exciting time to be here in
Miami so much has changed in the last
year and a half and it's everywhere in
Miami not just right here because
although I don't want to say the
specific part of town that I live in you
know and in the in the area that I
learned there hasn't been a home
breaking in 14 years I mean the the
flourishing is every day I wake up and
there's a new Los Angelino coming to my
town now I'm starting to worry but and
I've been in an elected office for 13
years so maybe there's a correlation
between the 14 and the 13th but look I I
think uh you're right uh people Miami
was the best kept secret number one
number two Miami has always punched
above its weight right when you think
about what is Miami I mean you could
arguably have someone who lives in Palm
Beach who is in Paris and they ask them
where are you from they say Miami right
just sort of this is this big thing
right this I always say Miami's an idea
it's more than a city and it's an idea
born out of a trauma what's a trauma
trauma is many people in mind were
kicked out of their country but were
exiled because a leader in their country
said give me all your businesses give me
all your property don't worry we'll make
everything equal and you know what they
did they made everything equal equally
miserable for everybody right and so we
are traumatized by that and I think
that's why miamians are so fundamentally
pro-america we're so fundamentally Pro
uh you know sort of fair market and free
market and we believe in freedom and
liberty right those are principles that
for us we we fought for right we we've
we've been my grandfather was in jail in
Cuba my his brother died in a Cuban jail
you know it's very very real for us
so on the tax side you you wrote a piece
in Wall Street Journal about a month or
a month and a half ago talking about
free markets and capitalism and why this
place is start is thriving so how does
it make any sense I thought you knew the
government just needs more of our money
to make things work but you're keeping
taxes low and so and we don't have you
know roads exploding and all sorts of
stuff yeah yeah it's it's so
counterintuitive how is it possible so
let's let's let me give you a real
example right if you are living in New
York City right now cost of living
differential between New York and Miami
is two to one so in New York the median
home price is a million dollars in Miami
median home price is 540 two to one
right in addition to that in New York
you're paying 50 if you're in the
highest tax bracket a lot of New Yorkers
are because again your cost of living
well they're all coming down here now
well but check it out let's do the math
right you're paying 54 cents out of
every dollar in taxes that means that
for every dollar you earn you take home
46 cents in Miami you get 63 cents right
it is a huge Delta right and so that
when you at scale obviously is Inc
incredibly uh motivating to people you
know I've seen statistics that 70
percent of the taxes in New York are
paid by 8 000 people and if that becomes
seventy five hundred and seven thousand
sixty five hundred you get what's called
a vicious cycle right you get massive
holes in your budget when those people
leave and there's only one way to get
more revenue for them which is to
increase taxes which creates more
migration more holes and I call it the
death spiral so what's happening now in
the United States is very similar what
happened to Detroit at the Industrial
Revolution right which is that you're
seeing this change from industrial to
digital and Miami is the only city in
America that got the memo and has
basically uh built its entire economy to
capitalize on what I call a tsunami of
opportunity and cities like New York and
and San Francisco and Silicon Valley
thought they were too big to fail and
I'll tell you Dave they're not
um the world is more disruptive than
other companies that are massive get
disrupted out of existence like that and
um we are building for the future and
it's exciting to see do you get any
pushback from other Mayors who are going
hey Francis you know if you keep taxes
low it's going to make us look like a
bunch of idiots because we got the grift
going here and it's kind of working
until until it doesn't work you know
I'll tell you this I'm President of the
U.S Conference of America so president
all the Mayors in the country
um and and when I get more of and I got
to be careful how I say this because I
get more of the camera's not on listen
we really think what you're doing just
great yeah yeah but we we don't have the
ability to do it it's that's more the
sentiment that I get right which is why
would it may or not have the ability
because of the local I think there's a
variety of reasons I think they get a
lot of pressure from the Press right
which has this their own agenda right
which is a grow government government is
a solver of every problem agenda I think
they've got to deal with uh institutions
like for example when I first got
elected in 2009 I was the only candidate
elected without Union support because I
wouldn't lie to the unions and tell them
look we're gonna raise your pay when
we're in a recession right you know and
when when we have to cut 20 of our
budget in one year which is another
thing that's another lie right which is
that government can't balance his budget
listen I had to 20 percent for my budget
in one year 150 million dollars at a 600
million dollar budget if I can cut
twenty percent in one year we can
balance our budget at the federal level
and the city didn't fall apart and they
said no I'm gonna contrary it started
thriving right so we balanced our budget
we were at 13 million in reserves at the
time 2009 in November now we're at 150
million reserves the most reserves we've
ever had we have the highest Bond rating
under my uh Administration ever in the
in the history of the city which is
double A plus one away from the highest
which is AAA so we're incredibly
fiscally sound uh and it's all by just
you're sort of following the same
formula that you would if you're a
homeowner right like your own personal
save a little bit of money pay off your
credit cards you know pay your debt uh
don't overspend right and then spend
strategically on the things that are
going to make you more successful invest
in yourself invest in you know policing
keeping people safe that kind of thing
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full up episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell